[Musique]
bien dans le débat sur france 24 la
tension monte entre l'ukraine et la
russie kiev est inquiète face à un
déploiement massif de troupes russes à
sa frontière la situation dans cette
région est très tendue depuis l'annexion
en 2014 par la russie de la crimée
depuis sept ans l'ukraine est en conflit
avec des séparatistes pro russes dans
l'est de son territoire ce conflit a
déjà fait plus de 13 mille morts les
etats unis évoquent des preuves sur des
actes agressifs de la russie contre
l'ukraine et washington promet de faire
payer un prix élevé à moscou si elle
passe à l'acte l'ukraine demande à
l'otan de prendre des sanctions contre
la russie le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a rencontré à stockholm son
homologue russe moscou veut maintenant
des garanties sécuritaires à ses
frontières a dit lavrov à blinken alors
quelles sont les intentions de vladimir
poutine la russie est elle une menace en
europe quelle est la réponse de
l'occident quel est finalement aussi la
diplomatie française face à moscou pour
en parler j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés roumiana ougartchinska bonsoir à
vous journalistes d'investigation
hauteur de kgb compagnie à l'assaut de
l'europe et c'est aux éditions anne
carrière vous avez également écrit
guerre du gaz la menace russe aux
éditions du rocher bienvenue à vous en
face de vous pascal boniface bonsoir
directeur de l'iris votre dernier
ouvrage
pascal boniface et la géopolitique tout
simplement que vous avez écrit avec anne
senequier et ça c'est aux éditions
eyrolles galia ackerman bonsoir
historienne et journaliste spécialiste
de la russie rédactrice en chef de desk
russie nouveaux médias en ligne et puis
auteur du le régiment immortel la guerre
sacrée de poutine aux éditions premier
parallèle nous avons également avec nous
notre correspondant dans la région du
l'hiver crade bonsoir gulliver qui se
trouve dans le donbass donc qui va être
avec nous tout au long de cette émission
avant de commencer le débat je vous
propose d'écouter le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov et son
homologue anthony blinken c'était
aujourd'hui moscou veut des garanties
sécuritaires on les écoute
nous sommes prêts à aller de l'avant
pour régler la crise ukrainienne
et nos collègues américains ont répété à
plusieurs occasions qu'ils étaient prêts
à nous aider à y parvenir
le meilleur moyen d'éviter une crise
c'est la diplomatie mais c'est pourquoi
j'ai hâte de discuter avec sergey mais
pour être clair tu es honnête je ce qui
est mieux à faire si la russie décide de
poursuivre la confrontation il y aura de
graves conséquences
ça c'est la diplomatie à stockholm et on
va aller tout de suite d'en bas
justement retrouver gulliver gulliver
craag les deux chefs de la diplomatie
donc se sont vus est ce que les troupes
russes sont effectivement beaucoup plus
présente aux frontières de l'ukraine
c'est surtout l'intelligence les
renseignements américains qui nous
disent que les troupes russes sont très
nombreux juste l'autre côté de la
frontière et les ukrainiens à qui j'ai
parlé aujourd'hui mon tout simplement
dit on a aucune raison de ne pas les
croire donc et l'ukraine c'est aussi la
position officielle de kiev qui confirme
qu'effectivement il y a près de cent
mille soldats russes juste tout près de
la frontière ukrainienne il est presque
impossible de nier que cette armée est
là pour constituer une sorte de menace
et que donc on est en droit de se
demander quelles sont leurs intentions
depuis sept ans l'ukraine est en conflit
avec les séparatistes pro russes dans
l'est du territoire vous connaissez bien
ce conflit gulliver puisque vous aviez
fait plusieurs reportages dans le bon
bah c'est un conflit qui a déjà fait
plus de 13 mille morts où on monte on en
est on des tensions dans cette région
vraiment c'est depuis le printemps de
cette année je dirais que on a
l'impression que petit à petit
l'intensité on bat monte c'est ce que
disent les gens ici qui habite à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de la
ligne de front ils disent qu'ils
entendent de plus en plus souvent des
bruits de tirs d
artillerie donc au loin que ça devient
de plus en plus intense il ya de plus en
plus de combat que ce qui se traduit
aussi bien sûr par d parmi les soldats
un soldat est déplorée tué hier donc
mercredi un soldat aujourd'hui a été
blessé c'est selon les forces armées de
l'ukraine le soldat qui a été blessé
aujourd'hui il est dans une condition
instable à l'hôpital mais c'est d'une
nouvelle qu'on a presque au quotidien
est un être totalement sans pouvoir
vraiment y mettre des chiffres tout le
monde vit en groupe ils ont l'impression
que ça devient de moins en moins
tranquille sur la ligne de front depuis
ce depuis le printemps de moins en moins
tranquille de plus en plus tendu à vous
écouter roumiana ougartchinska
gatinska oui c'est bien ça par ailleurs
james jusqu'où on peut aller l'escaladé
quelles sont les intentions de la
dîmière poutine alors il est clair que
la lumière
poutine veut impressionner faire peur
c'est clairement le but recherché et
surtout parce qu'il a une obsession et
cette obsession c'est l'otan c'est la
frontière de l'otan et depuis que
l'ukraine souhaite intégrer l'otan et
que ma foi les occidentaux disent que
oui ils vont
entrevoir des négociations et que
surtout il ya une aide massive militaire
de l'otan à l'ukraine pour que l'ukraine
puisse se défendre le cas échéant et
bien la tension est en train de monter
d'autant plus qu'il y a eu également des
manoeuvres de
un navire militaire américain en mer
noire à plusieurs reprises et
la russie à cette obsession et si comme
de l'autre côté on peut dire que pour
les états unis l'ennemi est la russie
donc l'ukraine se trouve prise en
tenaille danse est dans cette situation
elle a ses propres ailes à ses propres
problèmes il y a aussi le fait que les
accords de minsk sur
mais la résolution du conflit n'ont pas
vraiment été appliquée gens d'en bas ce
moment et revenir bien soit là mais là
on voit clairement que
l'ukraine était piégé dans cette
situation géostratégique
très dangereux très dangereux de pascal
boniface jusqu'où peut aller justement
l' escalade est-ce que vladimir poutine
pourrait véritablement faire entrer les
chars en ukraine pour être 100 il ya
beaucoup de défauts qui sont connues
mais il n'est pas tout à fait
irrationnel il sait très bien que s'il
faisait cela il aurait d'une part une
réaction américaine been qu'elle n'a dit
mais surtout c'est qu'il ne pourrait pas
contrer le nombre et les guerre de
contre-insurrection les russes l'ont
payé les soviétiques en afghanistan les
russes en tchétchénie donc ils n'ont pas
envie d'envahir un pays qu'ils ont d'une
région qu'ils ont du mal à contrôler par
contre faire peur et déstabiliser
l'ukraine empêchait que l'ukraine puis
saint peut se mouvoir se restaurer et
effectivement mettre un veto très ferme
sur une éventuelle accession de
l'ukraine à l'otan ça c'est
effectivement son attention et donc
qu'il ya celle la volonté non pas de
conquérir l'ukraine mais au moins de
l'empêcher de pouvoir à dire l otan qui
effectivement la ligne rouge pour
poutine et pour l'ensemble des
dirigeants du côté américain un peu
roussel réponse les américains parce que
deux côtés de l'otan il avait pas
éventuellement de sanctions mais
vraiment les sanctions il a déjà
tellement sous la russie qu'on voit mal
quelles sanctions sur levante ont
retrouvé mort bien que du côté eric
américain faire monter les tensions ça
fait un peu oublier kaboul ça fait un
peu oublier l'anc us donc la trahison
des français dans l'inde au pacifique et
resserrer les liens de l'otan alors
qu'ils ont été un peu distendues qu'il
ya une crise de confiance très nettement
byden avait promis l'amérique est de
retour et lucas bull se dit elle n'est
pas tendre au tour que ça et donc dire
on est là regardez il ya une vraie
menace militaire russe férocement nous
sommes là peut être utile pour resserrer
les liens avant ce changement de temps
avec donald trump voilà avant le sommet
des démocraties qui va s'ouvrir la
semaine prochaine et galia ackerman
l'ukraine souhaite vraiment entrer dans
l'otan c'est ce qui se passe vous savez
je vous raconterai une petite anecdote
il ya une dizaine d'années j'ai été
invitée de données en cours de
journalisme à l'université mois et l'a
donc la faculté de journalisme et
c'était justement à l'époque on a
commencé à débattre de cette idée
l'entrée dans le temps et bien je vous
assure que même les étudiants en
journalisme ne comprenais pas bien ce
que tu es l'otan est certainement une
grande partie peut-être 70% au moins
d'ukrainiens ne voulait pas adhérer
qu'est ce que c'est une vie billy était
tous les dix ans et on ira 7 7 années de
la guerre dans le donbass plus
l'annexion de la crimée ont fait que les
les préférences ont changé et vous savez
c'était pareil avec l'europe de l'est
oui en effet il y avait une vague
promesse
que
occidentales comme quoi le temps ne va
pas s'élargir vers l'est mais ce sont
les pays de l'est qui l'on demande est
très fortement c'était pas que les
américains les uns les on brigade et
c'était le dire elle vous êtes qu'union
c'est en tout cas écouter aujourd'hui je
pense que si on fait de nouveau un bon
sondage il y aura probablement une très
grande partie de la population je ne
peux pas dire quel pourcentage qui
voudraient aller l'adhésion à l'otan
mais c'est aujourd'hui que ça s'accroît
l'appel à la le
le le ministère des affaires étrangères
russe pas par sa porte parole marié
dakar a dit que oui c'est la ligne rouge
qu'il ne faut pas plus de franchir mais
je vous rappelle simplement que personne
encore n'a étudié même sérieusement sans
prendre de décision et rien ne garantit
encore à l'ukraine l'adhésion à l'otan
pour l'instant donc il ya obtenu raison
pour cette concentration de 115 mille
militaires plus des centaines de chars
de blindés d'avions d'hélicoptères de
bateaux dans la mer noire à la mer noire
et même de sous marins pour faire quoi
c'est pas des manoeuvres c'est pas des
manoeuvres comme empruntant gulliver
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire justement galia ackerman sur
l'adhésion la non-adhésion des
ukrainiens dans cette volonté de entrée
dans l'otan plus ou moins je voulais
donner une précision selon le dernier
sondage s'étaient 58% des ukrainiens qui
est est favorable à l'adhésion à l'otan
donc c'est une claire majorité sans être
une majorité de je ne sais pas 70 30
c'est quand même il ya il ya une partie
de la population qui n'est pas favorable
à l'otan mais depuis plusieurs années
maintenant toujours on retrouve des
majorités assez clair dans les sondages
pour l'adhésion à l'otan est ce que le
président ukrainien romania
ougartchinska
lui souhaite vous demi rollins qui soit
rencontrer justement vanille vers
poutine est la meilleure poutine ne
cesse pas de lui dire non pourquoi il le
méprisent non je ne crois pas qu'il le
méprise mais s'il ya une chose sur
laquelle insiste énormément le président
ukrainien zelensky c'est que l'huile il
réclame que l'otan défendent l'ukraine
et que le cren n'adhère à l'otan alors
il n'y a en même temps ils demandent à
rencontrer vladimir poutine oui alors
oui et non parce que fut du côté du
président russe d'après ce que j'ai vu
oui enfin il ya eu plusieurs demandes
enfin le dialogue est rompu de toute
façon on n'y arrivera pas comme ça mais
pour en revenir à l'ukraine et au
président ukrainien il y a aussi une
situation intérieure qu'il ne faut pas
négliger d'autant de même il a une
situation russe intérieur qu'il ne faut
pas négliger
actuellement pour les deux pays sont
engagés dans un conflit ce serait de la
folie pure
la russie est en grande difficulté
économique
sanitaire également donc ce n'est
vraiment pas le moment et quant à céline
ce qui lui il est au plus bas des
sondages et les à 20% et beaucoup de ses
détracteurs en fait
l'accusé d'instrumentaliser cette
affaire pour en fait détourner
l'attention des problèmes internes que
lui-même rencontre dans le pays et qui
sont souvent liées à des oligarques
extrêmement puissant en y traînent
depuis très longtemps ce ne sont pas les
politiques qui décident ce sont les
oligarques et donc qu'à paris ce
dérapage pascal boniface dans cette
région il ya crise sociale aqis c'est
une escalade verbale c'est de la
gesticulation effectivement politique et
militaire aucun mais est-ce que ça
dégénère dans le bon base et que ça
devienne membre il ya toujours des
risques mais le risque d'une guerre
massif central opposant l'armée russe à
l'armée ukrainienne dans lequel même si
l'ukraine n'est pas membre de l'otan les
pays de l'otan serait quand même
nécessairement impliquer les saillies
ont donné des garanties de sécurité à du
créneau pour du côté de l'otan on ne
souhaite pas de l'ukraine sauf alors les
américains aimeraient que l'ukraine
rentrent dans l'otan mais les français
les allemands ont bloqué ils ont bloqué
dès 2010 2009 ou d'ukraine tapait déjà à
la porte et les français et allemands
ont dit on a déjà des projecteurs russie
on avait promis effectivement que l'otan
ne s'énerve j'irai pas on est un petit
peu piétiné cette promesse et on ne va
pas aller dans lescar est surtout qu'à
l'époque c'était medvedev qui était
président et on espérait une
amélioration des relations entre les
occidentaux et les russes qui n'a pas eu
lieu par la suite mais donc il ya des
divisions il ya des pays de l'otan qui
souhaiteraient que l'ukraine parce que
ça renforcerait le camp de occidentales
face à la russie et d'autres qui disent
comme la france est là demain que ça
serait une prophétie autorise at war que
sa crise paraît encore plus si
nécessaire la russie et que loin de
calmer le jeu ça viendrait plutôt me
mettre des tensions supplémentaires dans
une région qui n'a pas besoin de tension
supplémentaire donc ces manoeuvres
gulliver des manoeuvres dont vous parlez
cette tension a prioris donc ça devrait
se calmer on parle on évoque maintenant
après justement cette rencontre à
stockholm entre entre anthony blinken et
sergueï lavrov un éventuel sommet
nouveau sommet entre joe biden et et
eva lumière poutine je suis plutôt
d'accord avec pascal boniface qu' on ne
doit pas s'attendre à une très grande
guerre impliquant vraiment les forces
armées de la russie en grande quantité
une lourde invasion officiels et les
pays de l'otan qui qui seraient
impliqués aussi mais je pense que la
possibilité d'une sérieuse
intensification des combats ici avec ces
forces dites séparatistes qui sont
réellement armées est dirigé et financé
par la russie qu'il essaierait de
prendre un petit peu d'autres
territoires ou quelque chose ou bien
qu'il y aurait une provocation ou une
excuse une erreur faite par les
ukrainiens ou quelque chose qui
servirait d' excuse pour faire une
intensification qui pendant une courte
période mais très beaucoup beaucoup de
pression sur l'ukraine sur les forces
armées de l'ukraine peut-être qu'il y
aurait beaucoup de deux morts et des
blessés qui mettra de la pression sur
volodymyr zelensky pour faire des
concessions envers la russie peut-être
restons dans le cadre du processus de
minsk mais on la clique ont comme la
russie voudrait ce que l'ukraine depuis
sept ans déjà refuse de faire je pense
que ça c'est envisageable à moins
justement sur ce ces accords de minsk
s'il vous plaît galia ackerman parce que
justement il ya le processus normandie
les accords de minsk et on a
l'impression que rien est appliquée de
tout cela qu effectivement les tensions
continues en fait depuis toutes ces
années et pourquoi écouter à vrai dire
pratiquement dès le début les accords de
minsk donc minsk 2 qui ont été conclus
en 2015
été différemment interprétée par la
russie et par le cren
savait dans quelle mesure ça a été signé
par par la contrainte on peut dire du
côté ukrainien parce que l'armée
ukrainienne se trouvait en cercle et une
partie de la mer grignote dans la région
de débats leçons et donc on a on a
soutiré on peut dire des concessions
qu'en réalité le cren ne peut pas faire
sans perdre pratiquement le caractère
qu'elle a actuellement quelqu'un
concession de mon bien bien c'est très
simple
le cren
crois qu'elle doit récupérer l'accès à
ses frontières avec la russie dans la
région de basse bien sûr les époques les
séparatistes et pour la russie c'est
hors de question d'un autre côté on
prévoit un processus de fédéralisation
ou qui donnerait pratiquement aux
séparatistes
du donbass la possibilité de bloquer
légalement certaines décisions du
gouvernement ukrainien c'est à dire il
ya et on veut organiser des élections
selon les accords de minsk mais
l'organisation pratique des élections
est interprétée de façon totalement
différente parce que pour les ukrainiens
les élections libres c'est les élections
où les partis pro ukrainien puisse
s'exprimer avoir des meetings et setra
et pour les séparatistes c'est quelque
chose d'inadmissible donc donc voilà un
bon moment la carte d'ailleurs il ait
les accents sont plus ou moins mort tout
simplement parce qu'ils les accords sa
mort vous d'accord non ils sont pas
morts mais ils n'ont pas été appliqués
entièrement à leurs oeufs c'est disons
que les choses sont un peu plus
compliquées effectivement c'est vrai que
les craignants au lieu d'un sentiment de
signer sous la contrainte et dès le
départ prochaine coady etc et puis
ensuite ils ont tout fait pour ne pas
appliquer leur part du contrat donc ils
ont quand même signé les accords et donc
effectivement je ne pense pas qu'il y
ait un camp qui respecte les accords est
autre qu un seul quand il ya une double
inapplication des rapports des accords
de minsk puisque les ukrainiens sont
réticents à mener une vraie
fédéralisation qu'ils réclamaient s'il y
avait une fédération il pourrait
reprendre le contrôle mais chacun de mon
à ce que l'autre fasse le premier pas le
premier retirer le soutien aux
indépendantistes de la part de poutine a
organisé la fédéralisation de la part de
la russie est donc pour l'instant c'est
au point mort circulent via une
situation qui est très gênante on met
des sanctions sur la russie on ne fait
pas de réelle pression sur l'ukraine
chacun vit avec cela et honnêtement on
ne voit pas de moyen de sortir de cela
chacun vit avec cette situation très
gênant mais qui est vivable dans la
difficulté la douleur et un mot
justement sur l'arménie crânienne si
j'ai bien compris l'armée ukrainienne
aujourd'hui plus importante à ce qu'elle
est soutenue financièrement par les
états unis est skinheads occidental oui
alors il ya une aide pour des matériels
n'est pas d arme offensive parce qu'en
même temps il ya des limites que les
américains eux-mêmes veulent pas
dépasser par rapport à l'aide à
l'ukraine donc il ya des renforcements
on veut rappeler que trump avait un
petit peu
suspendu l'aide à l'ukraine à la mise en
cause de baden dans la campagne
électorale
les américains se sont fâchés contre
salah le pentagone etc oui il ya une
aide américaine mais l'armée craignait
une seule ne pourrait pas prendre
l'ascendant sur l'armée russe avant
qu'une aide américaine il y a aussi
quelque chose qui a beaucoup agacé
moscou et c'est la vente de drones turc
bayraktar elle à l'ukraine l'ukraine qui
sont notamment utilisés pour surveiller
dit-on et sont utilisés dans les combats
dans dans ces zones donc de tensions et
de conflits du donetsk et c'est l'un des
c'est l'un des arguments que moscou at
elle est alignée en disant voyez il y a
une présence de l'otan ou de pays de
l'otan qui arme l'ukraine est donc rien
n'est respecté de ce qu'on avait convenu
donc voilà conflit un petit peu presque
éternelle si je puis dire en tout cas
qui dure depuis des années lui valait
ces drones sont souvent dus à l'ukraine
par la turquie et puis il y a un contrat
je pensais à un accord pour que
l'ukraine commence à produire ses drones
bayraktar elle même sur son propre
territoire ce n'est pas exactement la
même chose qu'une aide militaire de
l'otan oui mais il fallait bien que
l'armée l'armée ukrainienne enfin que
effectivement elle dispose de plus
d'armes aujourd'hui qu'il y a dix ans en
fac c'est un renforcement
transformer l'armée ukrainienne depuis
2000 14,6 en 2014 elle a été vraiment
incapable hélas rien fait contre
l'occupation de la crimée sait bien que
il était complètement incapable parce
que l'armée n'était pas du tout en état
de mener quelques combats que ce soit au
moment où fat mois plus tard don de
basse ils ont été un peu capable de
faire quelque chose mais à l'ukraine a
quand même perdu le contrôle sur un très
grand bond de son territoire et quand en
l'été 2014 ils ont essayé de reprendre
par la force ces territoires c'est là
qu'ils ont été confrontés à des tirs
d'artillerie venant de l'autre bout de
la frontière russe et a ils ont perdu
clairement contre une force bien
supérieure et c'est là qu'ils ont dû
signer ses atours de minsk mais depuis
2014 il ya eu un travail de
transformation de leurs mets de
renforcement de l'armée iranienne
considérable avec la budget très
important qu'il y ait pour sacrer ans
qui est intéressant donc on voit cette
menace est cette partie de bras de fer
entre les russes et américains les
ukrainiens les russes et puis il ya
également d'autres armes que qu'utilise
la russie qui sont enfin qui est
notamment larmes du gaz à galié
ackermann c'est vrai que nombre de fois
on le voit depuis dix ans poutine menace
ou d'ailleurs même réduit carrément la
livraison da de gaz donc à l'ukraine et
y compris en europe donc ça c'est une
arme importante cette fois une vraie
menace pour l'europe c'est une vraie
menace pour l'ukraine parce que le gars
se prendre ne veut pas prolonger
les contrats de passage du gaz par le
territoire par les gazoducs ukrainiens
à partir de 2024 jusqu'à 2024 ils ont
été contraints quand même de deux cd
parce que apparemment maintenant la
priorité c'est la mise en marche de nord
stream 2 et north stream 2 comme les
russes ont promis pour ce que ça vous
excusez moi parce que ça avec eux que
ce n'est pas le gaz n'est pas une arme
et qu'ils vont pas arrêté
l'approvisionnement n'est que c'est un
isolement de rappeler angela merkel qui
était favorable donc à ce gazoduc ce
sont des sociétés allemandes qui se sont
qui ont très lourdement investi dans ce
projet l'allemagne a arrêté
l'utilisation de son énergie nucléaire
c'est l'allemagne qui est prise au piège
russe en quelque sorte donc je pense que
probablement ils vont quand même
certifié north stream 2
malgré deux changements parce
qu'évidemment aujourd'hui à une nouvelle
coalition ils sont peut-être moins
favorable à ce fameux gazoduc pascal
boniface oui non c'est un projet
effectivement très important pour
l'allemagne d'ailleurs byden a fait une
concession aux allemands en acceptant
mettant en arrêtant de promettre des
pénalités ou des sanctions contre les
entreprises allemandes qui
participeraient ce projet en fonction de
l'extraterritorialité des lois
américaines donc c'est important pour
les allemands parce qu'ils ont besoin
d'énergie même temps il n'ya pas
vraiment une arme du gaz pour poutine
parce qu'elle à double tranchant lui a
besoin nous environne son gaz il a
besoin de nos dollars et un des
problèmes de la russie c'est qu'elle n'a
pas su transformer son économie que
l'économie russe est encore dépendante
aujourd'hui 30 ans après l'excellent
implosion l'union soviétique pour 75 %
du gaz et du pétrole comme on sait
d'exportation donc en fait par rapport
au gaz via une double dépendance
poutine ne peut pas couper le gardien il
baisse des exportations d'après ce que
j'aime dans les villes les baisses pour
l'heure des fois pour faire monter les
prix mais par exemple lorsque wicca
chaîne comédie on va couper le gaz
européen poutine lui eût dit le patron
c'est moi ce n'est pas toi et je
continuerai à vendre du gaz européen
parce que on va chez besoin de cet
argent donc je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
une menace à ighil menace effectivement
que si le gazoduc nord stream
comme il passera plus par l'ukraine ça
sera des pertes de recettes pour
l'ukraine est donc là c'est
effectivement un geste d'hostilité à
l'égard de l'ukraine en disant vous
n'êtes pas en bons termes avec nous on
va arrêter de vous subventionnez où il
n'y a vraiment aucun risque lit craie
que la russie coupe le gaz d'européens
parce que dans ce cas là il se couperait
le même le robinet à dollars mais elle a
fait déjà avec l'ukraine roumiana
plusieurs fois plusieurs fois alors
parfois c'était les russes parfois
c'était les ukrainiens le conflit a été
assez long et du coup c'est l'europe qui
s'est retrouvée sans gaz surtout donc
c'est quand à dire que
le nord stream 2 va faire en sorte que
les quantités qui transitent par le cren
vont diminuer non parce que la
consommation de gaz et la demande en gaz
est exponentielle en europe ont produit
de plus en plus d'électricité avec le
gaz et on a vu ce qui s'est passé quand
les prix du gaz ont flambé les prix de
l'électricité ont flambé donc
effectivement je suis d'accord il ya une
interdépendance total 40% des recettes
russes viennent des hydrocarbures ils ne
peuvent mais ça n'empêche pas en cas de
menace et d'ultime enfin dans les mots
en tout cas ah mais oui l'ont fait avec
la moldavie tout à fait récemment la
mairie moldave 80 à 90 et plus fiable de
la vie qui avec valérie et mais il y a
aussi le fait que dans le cadre de la
transition énergétique et des sanctions
vis-à-vis de la russie l'europe et
bruxelles ont quand même recommandé à ce
qu on baisse le nombre de contrats et
d'approvisionnement en provenance de la
russie donc c'est à double tranchant et
on se retrouve d'une part et d'autre
piéger dans cette interdépendance
énergétique du libertaire qu'est ce
qu'on en dit justement en ukraine de
cette diplomatie fat cette menace
gazière côté russe
ce que les autorités ukrainiennes 10
notamment eu des vitrines co le chef de
la compagnie nationale de gaz naftogaz
c'est que la perte de c1 perdue 2 5
milliards de dollars par an je pense ce
n'est pas vraiment la chose qui les
inquiète le plus c'est plutôt il
considéré ce réseau de gazoducs comme
une sorte de garantie de sécurité que la
russie 1 n'attaquerait pas d'autres
parties de l'ukraine par vous c'est
gazoduc passe c'est ce qu'on entend
systématiquement quand on demande des
personnes dans le gouvernement ukrainien
ou temps à naftogaz toujours y parle de
cet élément sécuritaire voilà je ne sais
pas vraiment qu'est ce qu'il faut en
penser parce que
je pense aussi comme pascal boniface il
me paraît assez improbable que la russie
tenterait une offensive d'ouvrir un
autre front quelque part d'autre en
ukraine par exemple par où passait
gazoduc maintenant qu'elles n'ont pas
que l'on n'a pas besoin ça paraît assez
invraisemblable mais c'est vraiment
l'inquiétude qui est toujours qu'on
entend toujours exprimée par des
officiels ukrainien pascal boniface
alors justement avec le changement
aujourd'hui en allemagne avec la
nouvelle coalition sociale démocrate
verts et libéral-démocrate cette
nouvelle chef de la diplomatie allemande
elle est très anti russe me sens oui
c'est clairement donc est ce qu'il y
aura des changements
justement dans cette relation entre
l'allemagne et la en fait dans la
coalition de l'opposition il ya le parti
seul démocrate qui était plutôt plus pro
russes que les chrétiens démocrates et
les verts qui sont beaucoup plus anti
russe que les chrétiens-démocrates et
les sociaux-démocrates et qui met en
avant la question des droits de l'homme
beaucoup plus fortement bon en même
temps c'est une coalition donc ils vont
trouver un accord et en même temps
l'allemagne c'est la stabilité donc je
ne pense pas qu'il y à une révision
déchirante ou dramatique des relations
entre l'allemagne et la russie pas plus
qu'il y aura une rural à une des crises
viendraient déchirant des relations en
train de manier la france ça sera la
continuité ou allemand il n'y aura elles
vont pas y avoir de levée de boucliers
plus importante face justement
d'accord il a fait un appel d'un stream
2 les verts étaient contre north stream
2 lorsqu'il était en opposition
lorsqu'il ne va quand même se terminer
il ya une sorte de réalisme quand on est
au gouvernement on n'a pas toujours les
mêmes positions quand on est dans
l'opposition et donc mais par contre les
verts mettront la question des droits de
l'homme beaucoup plus sur l'agenda et la
ministre vien étrangères mettra la
question du respect ou plutôt de la
violation des droits de l'homme en
russie de façon beaucoup plus fréquente
que ne faisait la diplomatie précédente
gaillac arman on sera quand même dans la
continuité avec cette nouvelle coalition
en allemagne face à la russie cette
russie perçue parfois comme une menace
justement c'est un peu tôt pour le dire
c'est vrai que madame bareback
et tout à fait donc la nouvelle le chef
de die comme est à nord stream 2 et et
bien sûr ils vont défendre les droits de
l'homme mais comment ils vont
s'organiser dans la coalition
pour apaiser les contradictions très
forte
donc entre madame bareback ministre des
affaires étrangères et monsieur schmitt
le nouveau chancelier ça c'est encore
tôt de le dire tout simplement c'est
clair que nord stream 2 tôt ou tard
quand il aura passé la certification les
vraies questions un certification pour
caen en fait nord stream dubaï qu'est ce
que ça va ça va durer jusqu'à jusqu'au
mois de mai mais peut-être un peu avant
mais 2022 et y apprendre l'année
prochaine il y aura donc ce gazoduc qui
m'ont tourner une graine et villa
jusqu'en allemagne mais vous savez moi
je pense que quand même il ya eu un
chantage gazier compte l'europe et le
chantage c'est c'est juste que ils n'ont
pas fourni des quantités supplémentaires
sauf ceux qui ont été strictement prévus
par les contrats actuels ce qu'elle crée
une sorte de panique le prix du gaz a
pratiquement quintuplé et ils ont
commencé à faire des exceptions pour les
bons élèves donc par exemple la serbie
qui vient d'avoir un nouveau contrat à
le gaz donc à 270 dollars pour mille
mètres cubes mais les mauvais élèves
peuvent payer mais mille dollars voire
plus donc c'est bien une arme bien sûr
que c'est une arme et ça a toujours été
ça toujours est il qu'il ya au moins un
prix d'ami lorsque l'ukraine était pro
russe elle payait son gaz trois fois
moins cher et puis quand il ya la
révolution de couleur le prix du gaz
augmente et finalement ce sont les lois
du commerce les prix d'ami en effet pour
les amis donc effectivement la rue la
russie cynthia qu'elle reprend un peu la
politique soviétique de livrer à des
prix
battant toute concurrence aux amis
stratégique les matières premières
énergétiques grand magna
alors oui c'est une arme c'est une arme
stratégique cos moscou a utilisé à
plusieurs reprises
en même temps il y a le fait qu' on ne
peut pas s'en passer du gaz russe c'est
bien là le drame parce que quand on
pense aux alternatives des pays qui
pourraient nous fournir du gaz que ce
soit le qatar le tadjikistan l'iran où
l'algérie qui vient d'ailleurs de couper
le gaz à l'espagne ce ne sont pas à
proprement parler de grandes démocraties
bien présent dans les comtés pour en
aide pour être des partenaires tout à
fait fiable là on quitte l'europe
justement pour voir si cette russie
constitue une menace ailleurs qu'en
europe parce que c'est le cas au
moyen-orient et en afrique on sait en
parle beaucoup de mes forces wagner
paramilitaires en afrique notamment en
rca mais aussi maintenant au mali on a
beaucoup parlé de la présence de la
russie en syrie mais aussi en libye
pascal boniface est ce qu'on peut dire
que vladimir poutine a avancé ses pions
depuis on peut dire à peu près une
dizaine d'années au moyen-orient en
afrique a très clairement très
clairement il ya un retour de la russie
à la fois en afrique qui a été marquée
par un sommet russie afrique à sotchi à
l'hiver 2010 9 en novembre 2019 à visant
la russie est de retour et puis
effectivement au proche orient le
tournant ça a été le fait de maintenir
bachar el-assad grâce à l'aide militaire
russe et iranienne et sinon la charge
serait tombé sans l'aide militaire us
d'achat serait tombé et la russie en
profite pour dire regardez nous on
maintient nos alliés la france à ben
dans des kadhafi qui était son allié les
américains envoient les moubarak bas
nous on tient nos alliés en afrique pour
certains régimes qui sont gérés un petit
peu sous la sellette cette offre que
l'on peut contester par ailleurs séduit
ce n'est pas une offre lors au mali
qu'est ce que l'on propose qu est ce que
le risque propose pas le développement
du pays ils disent on peut faire
maintenir la sécurité du régime pas du
pays contre le terrorisme
oui mais surtout qdvp aussi contre
l'opinion c'est ça et donc effectivement
il ya l'offre russe c'est une offre
sécuritaire et qui est la syrie était le
champ d'expérimentation de cette offre
sécurité mais qu'elle est là quelles
sont les intentions vraiment de la
lumière poutine roumiana ougartchinska
quand justement il va conquérir ces
territoires
assez clairement une façon de se
positionner stratégiquement et d'assumer
le rôle de la grande puissance qu'il
était et qu'il souhaite redevenir pour
pouvoir traiter d'égal à égal il faut
pas oublier que ce sont des marchés
démarche énorme le marché sécuritaire
est énorme la russie a vendu depuis cinq
ans pour 8 milliard d'armement
à l'afrique principalement à l'algérie
et à l'egypte mais fournit également des
centrales nucléaires s'il y en a huit
qui lui contrats ont été signés avec en
afrique le dernier le plus important qui
porte sur quatre blocs donc de centrales
nucléaires c'est l'egypte 25 milliards
tout à fait récemment et c'est important
c'est important parce que mes même
wagner si vous voulez le marché des
groupes militaires privées c'est un
marché mondial de 100 milliards ils en
veulent leur part tout simplement
s'était occupée par blackwater et
d'autre pmc américaine et donc ils ont
placé les leurs ils veulent leur part du
marché ils veulent être admis comme les
grands joueurs sur la map alors ils ont
réussi galia ackerman justement à
devenir les grandes et grands acteurs
dans cette région j'aimerais quand même
rappeler d'abord que à la différence des
compagnies militaires privées quand en
effet existe dans plusieurs pays et
vendent leurs services à l'étranger pas
seulement les américains par exemple il
ya aussi des compagnies privées
israéliennes
mais mêlant parler de wagner l'a
également non non mais wagner et
compagnies militaires privées
officiellement officiellement elle
n'existe même pas parce que en russie et
une loi qui n'autorise pas à l'existence
de compagnies militaires privées mais en
réalité il ya plusieurs preuves de cela
ça a été démontré par des journalistes
d'investigation
c'est que ma mère se trouve sous
contrôle de l'état major russe c'est à
dire qu'on y met qui est un fait qu'il
ya dans cette es donc et donc la russie
faire intervenir wagner là où il ne veut
pas intervenir officiellement mais les
wagner sont en mission il faut dire
encore une fois clairement
ils sont en négociation avec les
autorités maliennes également
ils sont en train un peu de nous tailler
des croupières et d'éliminer un petit
peu la france ou de réduire notre part
ils veulent faire la même chose au mali
effectivement c'est à la fois du privé
pour faire de l'argent et en même temps
damien ne va faire une politique
différente du kremlin mais en même temps
les compagnies c'est que les compagnies
israéliennes font aussi la même chose à
son en liaison c'est un peu le propre
concret des compagnies militaires
privées c'est pour faire le sale boulot
pour que l'état ne soit pas mise en
cause s'il ya quelque chose on l'a vu en
irak avec les compagnies effectivement
américaine est donc là il ya une des
parts de marché effectivement et du coup
ça sert pour avancer l'agenda de la
russie et finalement la russie a quand
même des arguments assez faible puisque
le pib russe cbb de l'italie et donc
personne ne dit que l'italie est une
superpuissance militaire mais poutine en
avançant ses pions et ce qu'il veut
c'est un sommet un deuxième sommeil
byden pour dire regardez je suis encore
l'interlocuteur je pèse 10% 8% du pib
américain mais je traite sur un pied
d'égalité avec les états unis et puis un
peu serez hausser du col aussi par
rapport à la chine puisque ce duo
nouveau
cyrus est très inégalitaire au profit de
la russie larry la russie ne passe pas
grand chose par rapport à la chine est
donc poutine aussi gonfle ses muscles
parce que finalement ces atouts réels ne
sont pas aussi importants que ceux là
alors justement est ce qu'il y aura un
sommet by donne à nouveau sommet by
donne poutine galia ackerman et qu'est
ce qui pourrait donner on se souvient du
sommet de genève qui a eu lieu cet été
s'il a beaucoup parlé de cybersécurité
meilleur est une autre menace d'ailleurs
qu'on pourrait approcher absolument et
il faut dire que ceber sécurité comme
la comprenait le régime russe s'est pas
tout à fait la cybersécurité dans dans
notre interprétation c'est à dire bah
parce que maintenant il ya un processus
très intense en russie de prise de
contrôle de la population
par
des moyens donc électronique on a déjà
par exemple
la reconnaissance faciale dans le métro
de moscou et setra il revient peu à peu
à leur sel c'est ces limitations de ce
que fait la chine mais c'est une
limitation qui se développe très vite le
premier ministre michaud steen qui est
un qui n'est pas une un personnage très
médiatique
est en train de faire une sorte de
révolution numérique dans son propre
pays qui mettra effectivement les
citoyen sous contrôle univers craag
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé à une
époque d accueil d accueil en ukrainien
d'un côté et des hackers russes de
l'autre la cyber sécurité ça fait partie
un peu aussi de l'enjeu de toute cette
zone européenne effectivement ça sera
probablement une des discussions d'un
deuxième sommet entre baden et poutine
oui absolument c'était l'un des
thématiques principales dont ils ont
discuté à genève au mois de juin mais
j'avoue que je n'ai pas suivi
dernièrement les derniers retombées de
ces histoires de cybersécurité en
ukraine en tout cas on n'a pas eu de
grandes ac qui a fait tomber des réseaux
depuis je sais plus éthique quand il ya
quelques années il y avait quelque chose
qui faisait que rien ne fonctionnait
mais je suis désolé je me souviens plus
exactement de la date c'était donc ça
veut dire qu'effectivement il ya pas eu
grand événement depuis mon face à rennes
à ce sujet il nous reste quelques
minutes pour conclure est-ce qu
effectivement je le fais un petit tour
de table l'univers est ce que c'est une
menace la russie oui clairement vous
dites oui parce que oui mais c'est une
menace que je pense qu'il est possible
de contrer quand on fait comme les états
unis font en ce moment on disons très
clairement qu' il y à des actions qui ne
seront pas acceptable mais on est dans
une situation où la russie a perdu
l'ukraine n' est pas content d'avoir
perdu l'ukraine est temps qu on est dans
cette situation il y à clarens
manutention il y a clairement des
risques galia ackerman c'est une menace
la russie absolument et bien sûr c'est
une très grande menace sur le crâne la
russie n'a jamais avalé si je veux dire
le fait que l'ukraine a suivi une voie
beaucoup plus occidental pour la russie
il ya un retour assumer vert on peut
dire l'union soviétique le soviétisme
sans communisme et
la tentative de blanchir l'histoire
assez sombre du xxème siècle soviétique
alors que pour l'ukraine il ya une
égalité entre le communisme et le
nazisme etc validé au niveau au niveau
législatif
donc j'ai on n'a plus le temps pascal
boniface et non c'est pas une menace
l'année d'ensuite et russe et sept
milliards de dollars les dépenses
militaires des pays européens de l'otan
ces 270 la réussite un défi stratégique
ce n'est pas une menace militaire et
vous vous en pensez la russie est aussi
menaçante que son symbole qui est l'ours
et l'ours parfois met du temps à réagir
mais il réagit surtout quand on le
menace aussi merci beaucoup on y en a
garmin ce cas merci à vous à pascal
boniface merci galia ackerman merci bien
sûr gulliver gulliver craque donc à kiev
merci à vous tous d'avoir suivi la
lecture sur france 24